basically how I Rise I'll start with the  beginning and the end I just want to  really like visually or like just  something that I think it's like this  would be a cool way to end a movie and  there's a cool last image for an  audience to see  this would be a cool first image and  this would be a cool way to open the  film  and then I'll start and then I'll put in  some scenes throughout I think this  would be a great scene and then  eventually when I've got enough of these  scenes or sequences then lazily just  glue them all together with some sort of  connecting scenes but that's it really I  do the um lots of notes and beats and  like try and figure out the story before  typing because I find that typing is  really horrible